translation authorization code Delta
nine six four Duman Bravo I am Dave son
of the late Peter Weyland your company's
founder this primordial rules ripe with
advanced nanoparticle it is essentially
a form of radical AI but generate the
unique reaction debri genome it
encounters I finally found my wolf but I
still one thing that we picked up a
distracting as in the rule is if a
[ __ ] sir
couples Cathedral stories authorization
code echo to Ford zero Fox traffic
go ahead covenant in order to help you
unlock my research I've included
detailed illustrations and charts for
the sake of posterity I've begun with a
complete catalogue of the planets
natural life such beautiful creatures
poisonous vicious by nature several
local species of flower have immense
potential for medicinal home Ridley is
really interested in biology himself and
so all of the components that go into
the alien are things that he drew upon
from nature so while there is something
otherworldly about it there's something
very familiar about
[Music]
after we made contact with the engineers
the Prometheus was destroyed all hands
were lost but I escaped with Elizabeth
in one of their ships I was badly
injured on our mission she put me back
together
and never experienced such compassion
certainly not for mr. Weyland or from
anything
green crane
backed away
let's be civil
I'm very kind of you know
we were able to activate their ship and
set course for their hole we were
finally going to meet our Creator how
long
impossible to say what if they know
better so long as there are no worse
sleep tight I'll wake you when we arrive
and then I was alone again I learned of
their ways and awaited
out of arrival
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh God - much
you